[Music]
harder
you're stronger than this diane
again
hey there it's mod garrett and welcome
to a filmtastic new episode of arty
essentials we're shining a light on some
incredible movies directed by women
these groundbreaking filmmakers have
brought a fresh perspective and paved
the way for a bright bold and balanced
future in cinema and what a journey it's
been going all the way back to the late
eighteen hundreds when elise jean bliche
became the first female director to 1984
when barbra streisand's film nental made
her the first and only woman to ever win
the golden globe for best director then
all the way up to 2010 when catherine
bigelow became the first woman to ever
take home the best director oscar more
on her soon though directors who are
women have often not received the
recognition they deserve they're
responsible for some of the greatest
artistic achievements in the history of
the biz especially in the last two
decades and that is where we will now
focus our attention these are our top
picks for 21st century movies directed
by women
the hurt locker catherine bigelow
oh god
[Music]
[Applause]
what's he doing
i don't know
what are you doing there's enough
banging there to send us all to jesus
i'm gonna die
one day comfortable starting with the
explosive war thriller the hurt locker
directed by catherine bigelow and
written by mark bowle it's the story of
staff sergeant william james who is a
part of a bomb disposal unit in baghdad
james and his team are targeted by
insurgents and find themselves facing
increasingly hazardous situations as
they struggle to complete their mission
and make it home in one piece
literally the film stars jeremy renner
anthony mackie brian garrity evangeline
lilly ray fines and many many others
[Applause]
though the hurt locker seems to have all
the makings of a big budget blockbuster
it actually falls into the indie film
category yeah i know it is hard to
believe the visual effects alone would
make you think otherwise never mind the
flawless cinematography the prominent
cast the fully authentic production
design and of course bigelow's
breathtaking direction so what makes it
an indie well it was funded by a
relatively small company known as
voltage pictures and this was one of
their first ever projects additionally
the film's budget of 15 million is still
considered low by industry standards
especially when you consider the
finances that other best directed
contenders had to work with that year
like james cameron with avatar which
cost over 237
million dollars to make
it's clear that even without the
resources of a major production bigelow
is an astute filmmaker crafty creative
and very hands-on according to her cast
and crew and her brilliance was rewarded
because the hurt locker went on to win
six academy awards which included best
picture best director and best original
screenplay the film was also a critical
triumph receiving positive reviews
across the board
pariah d-ries things have been crazy
but look i'm really sorry i'm booked out
it's just i didn't know that you
i wasn't expecting that
first kiss
it's cool
writer director d reese proved to be a
filmmaking force with pariah a 2011
drama that stars adepero odue kim wayans
and usha davis it follows a 17 year old
black teenager named alicay who lives in
the fort green neighborhood of brooklyn
alakay is learning to embrace her
identity as a lesbian while searching
for her first real lover and dealing
with her parents strained marriage it's
a beautiful story driven by compelling
performances and relatable characters
reese's career began when she studied
film at nyu and had spike lee as a
professor and mentor she went on to work
for lee on his 2006 films inside man and
when the levees broke which gave her
invaluable insights into the world of
directing and screenwriting it was
around this time that rhys also began
working on the script that would later
become pariah for her graduate thesis
she adapted this working version into a
short film of the same name and found
success playing this short at over 40
film festivals around the world even
winning the audience award at the los
angeles film festival i'm sorry all
right
i'm sorry i let her hurt i just need to
know if you sign paperwork yes or no can
you forgive me yes or no
you can always come back home
things are going to be different i
promise you
i'm not running
i'm choosing
with spikely executive producing rhiz
eventually expanded pariah into the
feature-length version we know and love
today
when the film premiered at the 2011
sundance film festival it took home the
excellence in cinematography award and
in classic snowball effect fashion the
awards just started piling on pariah won
the john cassafedes award at the
independent spirit awards the gotham
independent film award for breakthrough
director and outstanding independent
motion picture award at the naacp image
awards the best independent film award
from the african american film critics
association and many others reese's
career continues to flourish having
written and directed 2017's mudbound and
2020s the last thing he wanted the
former of which made her the first black
woman to ever be nominated the best
adapted screenplay at the oscars the
babadook jennifer kent
i'm getting chills just saying it i am
of course talking about the 2014
psychological horror the babadook
written and directed by australian
jennifer kent once again this feature is
the extended version of a short film one
entitled monster that kent had released
nine years prior now if you haven't seen
this movie you're probably wondering
what the heck is a babadook well it's an
imaginary monster sometimes manifests
into a physical form and wears a long
trench coat and a top hat but it's also
supposed to be the embodiment of anxiety
grief and depression but sometimes it's
mistaken as just your average monster
under the bed oh and it has really sharp
teeth like a shark
and prefers the formal title of mister
you know i don't really know what a
bubba duck is but that's because kent
being the genius that she is made the
creature up
[Music]
so
[Music]
the film stars essie davis and noah
wiseman and centers around a troubled
mother named emilia who discovers that
her son samuel has been telling the
truth about a monster that has entered
their home through the pages of a
children's book
amelia had already been under a lot of
stress having to raise sam without the
help of his father after he was
tragically killed in a car accident
while driving emilia to the hospital
during labour throw a babadook into the
mix and you've got a real mess on your
hands
kent's creepy offering became an instant
classic and was one of the best reviewed
films of the year
rogerebert.com called it the finest and
most genuinely provocative horror film
to emerge in this still very new century
and get this william friedkin who
directed the exorcist you know the
scariest movie ever made wrote the
following words in response to watching
the babadook i've never seen a more
terrifying film it will scare the hell
out of you as it did me i can't imagine
a bigger compliment
selma ava duvernay this bill has been
almost impossible to craft you hear me
you think you're juggling martin i'm
juggling too
i am a preacher from atlanta
you are the man who won the presidency
of the world's most powerful nation by
the greatest landslide in history four
months ago
and you are the man dismantling your own
legacy with each passing day selma is a
historical drama directed by ava duvenay
and released in december of 2014. it's a
gripping portrait of america during the
1960s when discrimination was rampant
and black people struggled for their
right to vote despite violent opposition
dr martin luther king jr led his
followers on an epic march from selma to
montgomery which culminated in president
lyndon johnson signing the voting rights
act of 1965. king is portrayed by david
arjello a performance that earned him
critical praise in his first golden
globe nomination dubane and or yellow
had worked together back in 2012 on the
film middle of nowhere which was
dubney's second feature also an
excellent film that i highly recommend
watching if you haven't already but back
to selma duvenay signed on to direct in
2013 and immediately started revising
paul webb's script webb had originally
written the script in 2008 with the
intention of brad pitt's plan b
entertainment producing but yadda yadda
developmental health years past you know
how the story goes we will not let your
sacrifice pass in vain dear brother
we will not let it go
we will finish what you were after
we will get what you were denying
we will vote
we will put these men out of office we
will take that power
we will win what you were slaughtered
for
the important thing is that duvernay got
her hands on the project and according
to her own estimations rewrote about 90
of webb's script she spent hours
listening to king's words and speeches
studying his vocal patterns his basic
sentence structures and nuances of his
phrasing and it's this attention to
detail that sets duvenay apart from
other writer directors however a
stipulation in webb's original contract
entitled him to sole credit on the
script so duvenay wasn't credited as a
screenwriter despite her notable efforts
but that didn't stop her from receiving
an outpouring of praise especially her
direction the washington post wrote that
director ava duvenay has created a
stirring often thrilling uncannily
timeless drama that works on several
levels at once she presents martin
luther king jr as a dynamic figure of
human scale contradictions flaws and
supremely shrewd political skills oh
when it was also nominated for a little
award called an oscar in the category of
best picture yeah this film rules
wonder woman patty jenkins
she's taking all the fire let's go
[Music]
the dc comics world had waited long
enough and finally in 2017
wonder woman was released giving the
titular superhero her first
feature-length solo film
well technically second if you count
linda carter's version that came out in
1975 but that was a tv movie and really
just a pilot for the wonder woman series
anyways this modern iteration was
directed by patty jenkins who had risen
to prominence with her 2003 film monster
yes all that time earlier jenkins had
proven to be a powerful creative and was
an obvious choice when the studio and
producers were considering directors
everything was easy peasy jenkins
officially signed on in 2015 and boom
the movie was made roland credits are
kidding
as is often the case with big budget
films the road to wonder woman was long
and treacherous
how can a woman possibly fight in this
fight
we use our principles i mean that's how
we're going to get the vote
although i am not opposed to engaging in
a bit of fisticuffs should the occasion
arise
going back to 1996 development for a
live-action wonder woman feature first
began with ivan reitman attached as a
producer and set to direct that fell
through then in 1999 sandra bullock was
rumored to be taking on the heroic role
that fell through mariah carey catherine
zeta jones and lucy lawless were all
rumored to be possible candidates for
wonder woman but nope then in 2005 kate
beckinsale was definitely playing the
part
actually no i mean angelina jolie and
now somehow we're already in 2010. the
point is it took a long time for the
right team to be assembled but it was so
worth the wait because this movie is
extraordinary with jenkins directing a
screenplay by alan heinberg and gal
gadot taking the lead it was clear that
the stars had aligned and the time was
right
wonder woman was a critical and
commercial triumph and had a tremendous
cultural impact jenkins and gadot teamed
up for the sequel wonder woman 1984
which was released in 2020 and a third
film is currently in development yes
with jenkins in gadot set to return hey
if it ain't broken don't fix it
can you ever forgive me mario heller
listen the fbi has been in here to see
me
the fbi
they asked me to wear a wire
i'm not gonna do that to you
i'm a good guy
uh and if they want me to be a witness
i'll lie
but
you are gonna pay me five thousand
dollars
i don't know what you're talking about
can you ever forgive me is a 2018
biographical drama directed by the
multi-talented marielle heller it
follows lee israel a frustrated
alcoholic author who struggles to pay
her rent in 1990s new york down on her
luck lee hatches a scheme to forge
letters by famous writers and sell them
to bookstores and collectors when
dealers start to catch onto lee's scheme
she recruits a suspicious friend and
doubles down on her trickery i guess
someone realizing they're in the wrong
and cutting their losses makes for a far
less interesting story the film stars
melissa mccarthy and richard e grant who
offer dynamic and heartfelt performances
the script was written by nicole hall of
center and jeff whitty and based on the
real lee israel's confessional memoir
that bears the same name you're friends
with um
julius steinberg yeah
she's not an agent anymore she died she
did
jesus that's young
maybe she didn't die maybe she just
moved back to the suburbs i always
confuse those two that's right
she got married and had twins better to
have died indeed
interestingly enough even after lee's
scheme was exposed and she was sentenced
to six months house arrest and five
years probation her letters continued to
circulate reputable dealers were still
selling the forge letters for prices
much higher than what lee had originally
been paid trickeries aside she obviously
had some serious talent and it's hard
not to admire her clever abilities to
make some extra cash i feel like her and
frank abagnale jr from catch me if you
can would have made a hell of a team
well you know a team of criminals
can you ever forgive me received a
positive critical reception with variety
writing that it takes an actress as
delightful as mccarthy to make such a
woman not just forgivable but downright
lovable mccarthy and grant were also
nominated for best actress and best
supporting actor at the 91st academy
awards oh and to answer your question
yes lee i think we can forgive you i
mean everyone knows what rent prices are
like in new york
little women greta gerwig well i believe
we have some power over who we love it
isn't something that just happens to a
person i think the poets might disagree
well i'm not a poet
i'm just a woman
and as a woman there's no way for me to
make my own money
not enough to earn a living or to
support my family
and if i had my own money which i don't
that money would belong to my husband
the moment we got married and if we had
children they would be his not mine
they would be his property so don't sit
there and tell me that marriage isn't an
economic proposition because it is
greta gerwig wrote and directed 2019's
little women her adaptation of louisa
may alcott's classic novel of the same
name though this film was the seventh
film adaptation of olcott's novel gerwig
brought a unique perspective to the
story and its characters the ensemble
cast included circa ronan emma watson
florence pugh eliza scanlon laura dern
meryl streep tracy letts bob odenkirk
james norton luis gerald and chris
cooper oh and timothy chalamet but i
feel like that was obvious since somehow
he's in every movie now are they cloning
him for this to happen for anyone who is
unfamiliar with the sisterly story of
little women it's said in the years
after the american civil war and follows
joe march who makes her living as a
writer while her sister amy studies
painting in paris and her oldest sibling
meg is busy marrying a schoolteacher
when the shy sister beth falls ill with
scarlet fever the family regroups at
their home in concord massachusetts
gerwig had been interested in this story
for a long time and had cited the book
as an inspiration for her becoming a
writer and director finding parallels in
her own creative journey and that of the
character joe
5.5
that's very generous
9
6 and that's it
mr dashwood if i'm going to sell my
heroine into marriage for money i might
as well get some of it
6.6
done
and you don't need to decide about the
copyright right now no i've decided
i want to own my own book
when sony first announced their plans to
adapt the book back in 2013 they had
attached screenwriter olivia milch but
after going through several producers an
alternate version was imagined and in
2016 gerwig was hired but not before
urging her agent to contact sony and
toss her hat into the ring of potential
writer directors gerwig's persistence
paid off and she was eventually given
the keys to the creative kingdom and
rightfully so little women was
commercially and critically victorious
it garnered six oscar nominations
including best picture best actress best
supporting actress best adapted
screenplay and best original score and a
win for best costume design just don't
get me started on gerwig not getting the
best director nomination
i cried 11 times in that movie 11.
the farewell lulu
is
young man
the farewell is a 2019 dramedy written
and directed by lulu wang it's the story
of a chinese-american writer named billy
wang who received word that her beloved
grandmother ninai has been diagnosed
with terminal lung cancer and only has a
few months to live bilia returns to
china under the guise of a fake wedding
to go bertley say goodbye to ninai why
covertly well because grandma ninai is
the only person in the family that
doesn't know she's dying the film stars
aquafina sema
dinan lin and xiao susan and was
distributed by a24 the company behind
the acclaimed films ex machina room
moonlight and the wildly popular tv
series euphoria
la la
wang's inspiration for the farewell came
from her own life experience which she
shared on an episode of this american
life in 2016.
in the episode wang discussed an
elaborate ruse that her extended family
orchestrated in order to bid farewell to
her dying grandmother much like the film
the family wanted the opportunity to say
goodbye to their matriarch without her
knowing about her own three-month life
expectancy i could see how some might
think that this is a pretty cruel tactic
but as wang's fictionalized mother in
the film poignantly explains the chinese
maxim is people don't die of cancer they
die of the fear so i guess the jury is
still out on whether this was a cruel
approach or not but one thing that's not
up for debate is that the farewell is a
heartfelt film with thematic depth and
well-placed humor and above all is a
testament to wang's brilliance as a
director
nomad land chloe zhao
the workhorse that is willing to work
itself to death and then be put out to
pasture and that's what happens to so
many of us if society was throwing us
away and sending us the workhorse out to
the pasture we work horses had to gather
together and take care of each other and
that's what this is all about next up is
nomad land a drama written and directed
by chloe zhao and released in 2020 set
in the south west we follow fern a
selfless widow who embarks on a journey
after losing everything during the
recession like a true nomad fern's van
becomes her home and her chariot
carrying her along the open roads of
america
the film is based on the 2017 novel
nomad lan surviving america in the 21st
century written by jessica bruder
hello coffee
i know you yeah hi dave right
yes
fern yes
have your uh can opener yeah yeah yeah
you do are you working here now or yeah
first year
so coffee shortly after the novel was
released actress francis mcdormand who
plays fern and peter spears decided to
option the film rights to the book
mcdormand had been impressed by zhao's
film the rider and approached zao about
taking on the project zhao agreed and
film began in the fall of 2018. similar
to xiao used real-life ranches in her
film the writer she also used real-life
nomads in nomad land giving both films
an unrivaled authenticity
nomadland took home three oscars best
picture best actress for mcdormand and
best director for zhao this made zhao
the first asian woman and only the
second woman ever to win best director
at the academy awards the first being
catherine bigelow
the power of the dog
jane campion
what is it george
oh you just
don't want to see how nice it is
not to be alone
and last up we have the power of the dog
a western drama written and directed by
jane campion based on thomas savage's
1967 novel of the same name it's the
story of phil burbank a handsome cowboy
whose true desires are hidden beneath
his rugged exterior phil's moods swing
from furious to cunning and he unleashes
his cruelty on his brother's new wife
and her sensitive son peter but as time
passes phil seems to take a liking to
peter and reveals a softer side when he
takes the boy under his wing teaching
him the cowboy ways i wonder
what little lady made these
actually i did sir
my mother was a florist
so i made them to look like the ones in
our garden
oh well do pardon me
it's somewhat open to interpretation
what phil's true intentions are with
peter but their relationship is
certainly tension-filled to avoid
spoilers i'm just going to stop right
there but keep one thing in mind don't
ever underestimate peter the power of
the dog features dynamite performances
from benedict cumberbatch kirsten dunst
jesse plemons and rising star cody smit
mcphee all of whom received oscar nods
for their work additionally the film has
been nominated for best picture and best
director garnering 12 total academy
award nominations the most of any other
film from that year so there you have it
our top selections for 21st century
movies directed by women as always we
couldn't include every title that fits
the bill there are far too many
noteworthy films by brilliant women to
squeeze into one segment but don't worry
there are plenty more episodes of rt
essentials coming at you so stay tuned
i'm sure we'll get there soon thanks
again for tuning in i'm maud garrett and
shout out to all the aspiring women in
film the future is yours
[Music]